[Music]
over the last people recording a podcast
in 2018
we might be will I in a small group kind
of it's like sort of like when movie
reference when Indiana Jones slides
under the the you know the stone door
and the Raptors had yeah yes yes made
last episode last Anson Rambler of 2018
the year as that assumed so many things
Aretha Franklin is gone got dinner she
is what else
Floyd Mayweather just fought insane yeah
he fought a kpop person do you guys
think a punch can knock someone out or
more or a kick or is the same thing
anything only both both could knock you
the [ __ ] out but do you think a
professional boxer punch versus a kick
there someone's unexpecting could knock
you out but they just both if somebody's
just trying to do that don't really
honest it's fireworks I'll just keep hey
they're gonna have you with the
fireworks out in Maui yeah it's only
7:30 it's almost I mean I'm gonna say
this someone am I gonna be the you know
Lucy cave just edginess but my it's
almost as if we're in a Mexican
neighborhood back at the crib kind of
like you know Logan Square it feels like
that because I think over here on this
side of towns were the people who work
the working-class people live you know I
saw some one-bedroom Apartments on the
way over here so this isn't the fancy
Saturday it's nice it's funny that you
brought that up because one of my homies
George yeah he he said that they used to
have like neighborhood battles see who
could who got out the best firework
shows so everyone would post up on
blocks and try to just outdo each other
so they'd be just antsy
it's like that's how he's doing the
Latino you know yeah
battles firework battles I had a vibe
here in vahana
no wim ye look cool why the cool that's
I wasn't listening to the google-mapped
person say the Hawaiian streets and they
did good the robot did real good
ethnically saying these streets they
probably that's I don't think that's
awful first try they probably got some
angry emails but there's a robot don't
do they make the robots to say it better
robots mess up and say streets weird as
hell sometimes then oh I know but dude
I'm saying they set up streets weird and
then somebody's like you know Google is
disrespecting my culture right here is
the pronunciations you need to say each
Street five times on a voicemail and
then I'll be quite honest with you guys
man I have I have no idea where I've
been where I've been going where I am
I've just been hopping in the car and
just going I swear feels like the last
viewing nice we've been everywhere in
bed but I just can't remember it
what am i doing what am i doing it's
hard and you're not even dealing with
that much landmass this is hard I mean I
haven't even there's like like you said
there's like two Luber drivers here yeah
so it's like I haven't even been calling
cars I've just been going on the whim of
whatever everybody else is going like
this is the first time that's ever
happened to me where I just went to a
strange land and just was like [ __ ] it
let's go the island culture they going
hard yeah the best but that's that's
kind of authentic podcasting people are
getting a taste of what's really going
on on the last podcast of 2018
yeah as you are listening to something
special they have a podcast be out they
out having fun working yeah speaking fun
now speaking of new different lands we
hung out in Africa yes we did
Lagos Nigeria let me tell you something
man yeah you know we talked with Jack's
chit chat that trip has changed my life
yeah horse it has changed my life too
worth it like I'm like super focused on
[ __ ] like I like but [ __ ] movie we
about to do some other [ __ ] we better
have fun and wear tunics every day
man were too nice every day so it's I've
been made of suit sauce yeah i'ma tell
you that trip was amazing yeah we kick
it I mean it's not like yeah I was
watching you guys and the socials it was
funny cause it was just like crazy to
see Hannibal in a tunic like you like I
could see Brian in a tunic no problem
yeah and I saw that first Hannibal tunic
pick I was like nah then I saw another
wise I nah it's a crock that [ __ ] out
stage I'm like ok ok ok somebody's
getting a little fashion-forward now
taste it
let me tell everybody how it that way I
want to hear this treatment is do this
okay so he gets there like a few days
before me so he was already has been in
Africa maybe two or three days before me
I get there and we go the first day we
get there with you at the Afro Tech afro
I was at TechCrunch TechCrunch at
TechCrunch it's a tech conference in
Nigeria and I meet him in the lobby of
the event and he's wearing jeans a
t-shirt and like he had a notebook and a
pen and he's like in a hat sleepy yeah
man tired let's go ahead go this
conference go in take a few notes we
take a break he's a oh [ __ ] I got a
package at the lobby I'm gonna go to my
room he goes his room he comes knocks on
my door in a head-to-toe tunic suit hey
man boom what's up let's go African man
he chases shoes I think I got the
solution he has some like some cream
shoes to go with this [ __ ] here the toe
dude it was like he had drink 19 lattes
in a giant butt you act like that's
never happened to you before a fresh
outfit fresh outfit we'll get we'll pull
that out of you wings man I'm gonna kill
it tonight he was [ __ ] like dude [ __ ] no
joke he was just a good [ __ ] and a
minute later got a new head to toe to me
yeah I remember bad velocity I gotta get
a suit I gotta get bills I gotta get one
to orous exclusive is the designer yeah
came to the room fitted us up you know
men did our measurements I mean this guy
hit you guys up just randomly and say
hey let me let me set you up where did
you hit no no I
sooo I met this this woman glory out
there she's a singer and then we were
gonna go out to eat now they actually
can you take me I need to get one of
these suits so she took me to this
designer Tiana and Tiana she designed
she's done clothes for wizkid and a
bunch of other she's done something for
Sierra also okay so she took my magic we
would have bought fabric and then went
back with the fabric she took my
measuring for the fabric separately said
yes Bonnie about the fabric at another
spot and and then she had them ready in
a few days and then basketmouth
recommended his guy also so we I had to
separate and tailor situations out there
it was funny cuz we got we got our
little group text and and then he posted
that picture up with him with the tunic
on and I was like man I've been rockin
tunics and then he's like yeah but Yoshi
is not wet like my I said yeah it was is
not as wavy I've been rocket tunics for
a minute you know that but it's like I
would get me if I'm not by you guys but
I get baby [ __ ] it's like oh there goes
that do with the blouse it is a unique
look but you get things gonna believe
yeah you gotta believe and I think the
thing is says they're custom they fits
so perfectly yeah where it's like that
doesn't look nice those weird but it
looks nice like you yeah you know I'm
staying at this this resort here in Maui
and these white people
I just really can eyeballs full h1 of
this process of what's going on like why
does my forget the pool and this outfit
like this yeah it's a different thing
like Mikey
blue white kids is like you don't look
yeah look nice is you look like a
basketball player but you know why yeah
I have this uh this outfit on but it
feels great it feels great I'm rocking
my all-white dinner today you know
that's why that's why
we're mines I like your blue one the
best with the stripes on the inside that
wash like that won't look action because
like tunics are like still on trend like
they a while they were like and then I
remember because you know I have that
men's store mmm and then where I had to
draw the line is you know like in
Morocco men wear it basically dresses I
forgot what they're call but they're
like a head to toe
they're like straight up dresses mmm and
there's an open hands to it there's no
pants it's just a it's all the way up
and down so I was like I don't know what
most definite most definite yeah and
some people can I'm not saying that it's
whack as just that's where I drew the
line I was like I can't that I can't
pull that off it takes it takes a
special person but it's um I've worn on
stage feel good how was it needed you
show when yours felt good I rocked it
once in Nairobi when I did a pop-up show
and I wrote me on Christmas Eve and felt
great and then rocked it for our show
I like the black yeah yeah but you've
nothing black you get the it you got to
take it all in mm-hmm you know like the
lighter colors like oh that's a fool so
you know black is like us it's so classy
looking
yeah it looks sleek but yeah there's a
fun trip man hanging with basket mouths
you had some troubles in immigration
right yeah flew in almost got deported
that's my new my new starter joke of my
set how black men get to pour out of
Africa which is crazy as [ __ ] today
powering through telling this story
through a strong 20-second stream of
fireworks yeah that's a box of fireworks
like a Gatling gun back to my
immigration yeah immigration story I've
never felt so Mexican
yeah to get your order that's just
second shot at Mexico's what's one you
want us to edit out edit this down to
like Brian talked about Mexicans in the
Mexicans you know Mexican great no they
were absolutely got so too extreme Trump
where they had my back on on the to get
check back on the flight to get out of
Africa and was putting me a ticket cuz
he didn't have you had to have a visa
and the visa didn't come through he
hadn't come through in time and so they
were about to send him back like booked
a fresh ticket and put him back on the
plane you came in all right like I'm a
Klan I came in on back to Dubai and I
was like I was gonna break my heart how
my body couldn't take it so what was so
so so basket mouth full-blown rock star
at that [ __ ] yeah he's like yeah you
were yeah you were telling me he's like
a mayor over there it's home right
he came in and and that should disappear
he's just walked in and said here we
take it he walked in he's like don't
worry Brian I'm on my way and he was
like why like I mean he had a struggle
to get to that Airport cuz traffic he
made it so he got there in what two
hours a zone he got there quick did we
they just had you in like holding over
they had me like at the just sitting in
between the TSA and the gates there's
like the little seats there and you just
as I say that Alaskan all day no I back
him up came and then he left and then he
said he left he bats my would love to do
there just to wait with me there
so he just went like talks and then that
was that he posted it on Instagram I'm
like thanks to Colonel blah blah blah
for maybe we should even be talking like
this oh yeah
what do you did yeah I don't know maybe
we should be talking about yeah cuz I
mean Nazir is corrupt ain't no ain't no
but I got there with best trip of my
life and I kick it man I can't wait to
go back yes it's gonna be I think I'm
going back and I March okay yeah your
whole it's funny because like we can't
go to a spot anymore without you being
like like oh man it's not like Africa
over here like you just keep like I've
noticed that you keep going back there
well that's where I last was I mean like
Maui and I'm like oh yeah it's like so
many black people to zero black people
yes this thing it's a lot I mean I spent
a day and a half at home in Chicago not
really I didn't really go around that
much I go out but uh yeah so pretty much
straight from straight from Nairobi
Kenya to Maui over the course of a few
days you know I know this is how is
everything is just energy is just from
going to uh from you know just a
bustling kind of energy to the the
vacation either vibes is a whole thing
just the music and it's a lot it was it
was funny cuz we went to that we went to
that club we went to a club and beer
yeah yeah like bunch people were dancing
say this crazy man because in Africa
people will have rhythm and [ __ ] because
it was just people dancing all goofy
yeah I've turned it to a nineteen
eighties nineties comic in Africa but
you know what it's true yes sir
I need a buddy a buffer place man in
between Nairobi and Maui I was sort of
like again Miami four days and maybe
Cuba or something in a Mexico City it
just bounced around just to get a bunch
of different Atlanta it's just some
other stuff just some buffer cities in
between yeah New Orleans this is extreme
like it was the black guy at the
advantage rental car place you people
came with us you know yeah and other two
black people who at the Westin Hotel I
have not seen any black people outside
of the black people I know it was him it
was a handful of folks at the show
really yeah I couldn't yeah I wasn't
really look I didn't see ya yeah but
it's like it's like what 0.8 percent
yeah it's not even a lot on in Honolulu
actually on Oahu is a low percentage
also but it's more I guess it's more
because of military but yes not a lot
never saw although that do for magnum
p.i TC he was a unique brother huh yeah
no your time he's a fictional character
page that was a black man who is a
helicopter pilot who kicked it with
magnum p.i mmm-hmm and they will solve
crimes and [ __ ] but he was like it was
over here in Hawaii in the 80s man so he
was unique but he had a military
background yeah oh yeah it's just funny
being out here you talk to people having
we were talking a lot of people
a strip that people to add corporate
jobs you know in Ohio or Michigan and
just give it up say to coke and then
move here and be a bartender or
something yeah yeah some days check out
just check it was just moving just I'll
just rather I'd rather be warm and have
a flexible schedule and now to be by the
beach a man through this do you think
those people have that corporate job
enough to put you know investments you
know it's like sort of those those what
did they say right yeah you know your
average person's can't quit be broke so
they're there because someone has to be
broke I think I mean isn't it too much
to move somewhere I'm sure I mean
everybody I'm sure there's some people
that I'm sure there's some people that's
prepped properly
yeah and plant they plan to move out
there if I'm gonna do this five years
I'm gonna put aside this much per week
how much this is my budget I'm not gonna
spend on this and then at the end of
that five years I'll be able to move to
Hawaii and be learn to be a tour guide
and there's some people that probably
just abruptly just had to break up as
I'm moving Hawaii yeah so it's different
different situations I'm sure but I just
wanted to brought that I'm sure there's
some regret too when you get that
sticker shock love you know average
things cost in 20 30 percent more what
the [ __ ] oh no it's 350 really but
cheaper than New York City were there
for $12 for two blunts
I don't know what happened with swisher
Sweets in New York man man y'all get the
hustle for blunts anyway what a hustle
rolling away all in a product anyway
that's true man imagine you're thrown
away like over 50% of the price no you
know what that is a great point because
you buy that [ __ ] and then you don't
have it
it's more than half like buying pre-made
sandwiches and just keeping the bread
slices throwing the rest out oh yeah now
I can I can do what I want with this I
get it now this road is what simple it's
like buying a cup of coffee and then
just pouring out of it out like what the
[ __ ] like that's so crazy
listen trees business my oh yeah that's
it like it's a great business model what
what was a rap show recently Chicago and
it was sponsored by Philly's blunts they
started at Danny Brown so yes yeah
Phillies Phillies Wow I was like oh so
Philly smoking still smoked Phillies
Feliz was like paper bag yeah they won't
even rap and they were they were like
but that's what all the rappers were
talking about this brand Laura wouldn't
when they first came out but then read
people realize that this is a horrible
smoke but then people started saying I'm
gonna up optimist no side the optimal
Garcia Vegas horrible smoke I think I
think social sweets came out with the
with the unique leaf and paper that made
the smoother smoother smoke I love how
you talk about it like you're a wine
connoisseur male yeah alright let's get
back how do you feel like the Africa
trip has changed you we didn't get into
that house change means this like I
realized when we're at the aft ech lunch
when I had that movie idea as like man
we are not going to our full potential
of our demographic meaning that there's
so many other people like us in the
world but we still trying to [ __ ] with
Cleveland yeah I'm saying like you know
I'm saying or in New York or whatever
it's like Lagos is three New York's
right twenty million my pockets you know
I'm saying we're here you know laughs
laughs doctor just do
you know hanging out with us and giving
us Raj and she's kicking it with us you
know he goes away 200,000 Instagram
followers I got five and he's just
gotten started economy you don't say it
because it's more volume it's just more
energy and once you get that Africa
market then you get Europe because this
Africans in Europe these Africans and
Canada I'm saying where America becomes
like it's gonna be there for you but if
you just look outside the box so I'm
about now man your worldly guy worldly
guy and I realized like it's some in
just people how people were coming up to
you on the streets you know people you
know like oh my god Hannibal Buress what
are you doing here I love you baby watch
actually happened today and you to do
for Baywatch and I was like I haven't
heard that one in a minute you know what
I'm saying like is there people trying
to sleep like a lot of people trust act
like Africa they don't got TVs they
don't have you know they don't got [ __ ]
yeah where it's like you know I clearly
got [ __ ] they clearly plug everybody got
a phone everybody but it's sort of like
been ignored and in business try to get
anywhere people in there yet right
ain't nobody [ __ ] what I'm so I was
like let's be that's just so [ __ ]
with them yeah man I kind of I
definitely get motivated to just try to
just really push in general just it also
hidden trying to hit different markets
but just really push and be more
creative and productive and have a
thoroughly just a higher output I don't
think I've been really quite good
cranking it and just kind of just really
and insist and not only I I want to see
what it's like when I do that I feel
like I've been coasting most of my
career outside like little pockets where
I would do a lot of sets but even then
when I was doing a heavy amount of sets
doing 15 18 shows in a week I wasn't
even maximising
because I wasn't filming each show I
wasn't reviewing it and doing notes and
and really working on the sounds is
doing them it is progress to be made
from performing a lot and repetition all
that but I wasn't even then I wasn't
working it how it could be work the most
optimally so now I'm like okay let's
just really work [ __ ] and be thorough
and and push for a whole year or a whole
half a years and see what the results
are from that because the real thing is
from that trip the number thing that
stuck stuck with me is the doobly he
taught my basket mouth you know he's
like he's a man over there and when he
told me how many shows he shoots per
season for his TV show yeah I'm like oh
you [ __ ] work wait what's what's the
show he sent me my flatmates so what are
they what's the show about what's the
premise flatmates roommates think
Melrose Place but African dude was a
sitcom yes novella format is it I think
he said it was a couple hundred per
season you know two hundred it was 250
something per season first season at 150
something shows per season
they crank it out they do is that even
possibly doing it sort of like you'd
like soap soap opera style so they're
just like probably what rip like taping
like 12 episodes in the day or some [ __ ]
like 2 to 2 or 3 and they shoot for like
six eight months it's like crazy dude
that's what I'm saying like point you to
make it I'm saying ain't [ __ ] easy and
Legos you got a work shift you got to
get to the airport on time you got a
[ __ ] work to man have you got a
[ __ ] work yeah and that's that's the
I think that's what you saying man it's
like that extra well your guy humble was
saying like 80% is just showing up it
ain't that yeah a lot of stuff is show
but then too you just gotta that's
pushing it though so but I also think
that that episodes thing is just what
their market requires or what the this
how they that's how they do things
how do you stay sane with a schedule
like that that's that's thing I mean in
that I think is well I mean if it
working most of the year is just it
probably just doing things quicker and
less takes yeah and he's probably he's
probably super pro biting I'm because
the first time you told me about this
guy you told me he was like cuz I never
heard of him we were in Johannesburg
yeah and you were like there's this guy
named basket mouth out here and he's
like crazy famous well yeah I looked
them up afterwards
I met him in Joanna's but I looked him
up after that and it was just it was
some video one of those kind of Dateline
style interviews and they whip the
person walks through their own
neighborhood and then it was they were
interviewing him and it was his children
chasing him through the streets was like
Jesus he came in in a fitted suit nice
shoes no it's time for glasses is he
always fresh always fresh always cool do
do their thing is women from like London
from Belgium what come on I saw you in a
show in London I saw you the shoulder
I'm saying is like that thing this knew
him from like like that that's dope man
he's got power man so I'm saying like at
the end of the day dad do was inspiring
for me from that trip to like oh I've
been I've been sleeping I've been
slacking because once you get in the
groove in the groove man you you know do
a couple of wait wait don't tell me
they're like oh [ __ ] it man this
this would [ __ ] that you want to be a
comic rockstar yeah I want to be basket
mouth how would I have grown man take a
47 acting like I'm the Beatles you don't
say like okay so question yeah you said
I think one of you guys were saying like
it's part of the uniform right that did
they just walk around with ak-47 akm
we're just I'm saying like the the cops
right dealers the cops yeah just ak-47
thats crazy even security guards would
have loved this is uh so a security
guard at the club at the club or even
just a security guard late night at an
outdoor ATM just the [ __ ] fully
automatic just a fully automatic not
even a police officers just I'm like the
ATM no it was a dude at the first hotel
we stayed at what we did TechCrunch it
was a man who had his own security guard
and that dude had a ak-47 and he just
got an elevator with his man now here's
a question is this are they being extra
or is this like is there is there an
actual real threat where you're gonna
need that fully automatic weapon I'd say
so Wow well I think if you don't have
one you get you just can't come up and
not have one yeah yeah you think you
just got out of hand like you got one
I'm gonna get one all right then we're
all giving everybody better or you
better be like you have two Glocks and
to be a great shot that's just crazy to
me that people walking around with fully
automatic weapon and they don't have it
they were having Rambo style where you
will you duct tape two clips together
I saw multiple dudes hair two clips duct
tape so you'd fire then you flip it
around then you have a duct tape like a
Jimmy rig like yeah extendo cliff yeah
the duct tape you know I I watched this
documentary cuz I start I got into a
Africa internet wormhole while I was
there in jet-lagged and just up until I
saw so I was upset with myself about
that I would be jet lag
but then I wouldn't work during the jet
lag being awake when I'm just at the
room from 2 P 2 a.m. to 9 a.m.
wide-awake I didn't make the most out of
that time I did watch a lot of YouTube
and I found out as a 11 or 12 African
countries that used to be French
colonies that still have to pay a crazy
colonial tax and combined it's about
five hundred billion dollars a year with
those twelve countries that they have to
pay to friends and so those countries
are kind of [ __ ] financially because
of that and so I was reading about that
and then they said it's been going since
the 50s or 60s and when a president
doesn't want to pay that they'll they'll
just have a coup and just get him
assassinated and put somebody else in
power so and they'll have like a warlord
be president so then I started reading
about African warlords and then I ended
up fighting about this guy general butt
naked
is that the one we were watching yeah
did the cop right no no okay go ahead
the cop was this guy of my receipt and
in Nairobi just got general butt naked
but is it spelled that way I felt funny
no is general butt naked early you TT
okay na ke like so he's like there's a
story behind the name it was uh
he fights naked then he would get other
his soldiers to fight naked in in
Liberia
and now his part he said being naked
gave him power and so he'd be running
through naked killing [ __ ] and
he killed lots of people and now he's a
preacher and so he was going around
preaching and apologizing to people who
family members he's murdered and but he
was just really manipulative and kind of
a sociopathic [ __ ] about it cuz he
would say you have to forgive me he
wouldn't say you will will you forgive
me like okay pull this back a little bit
okay first question so him and a bunch
of soldiers we're just running around
naked this is doing a war yeah but do
you have guns yeah so where would they
put their bullets and stuff I don't know
man
so probably had bags issed I mean that's
you know okay probably had bags right
number one that and number two fanny
packs he's a preacher you said what
religion christianity christianity
yeah muslims not going to take that you
can you can walk you can finesse they're
not going to get into what your religion
is right wrong but it's just it that
sounds like a Christian thing to do
gimme your watch this forgive me I don't
know it's pretty wild man speaking of
jet lag a Hannibal well we've stayed in
Nigeria I woke up and this dude left me
a jet lag mystery if you remember this
Hannibal I went to bed we don't have any
cash no drink in the house no food
nothing right
I'd doze off I wake up it was like 4:30
5:00 in the morning right wake up this
dude's gone cash on the bed pepto-bismol
drinks snacks all downstairs is nowhere
to be found and he locked me inside
okay physically like cuz you have to
take the key in this like a double lock
see you a person can't lock it you hit
you have that Mikey wait so lookit so
this so this apartment could be served
as a loft as a prison it could be yeah
yeah a strict daddy like you have a
daughter you know I'm yeah double-sided
lies purpose why does I don't want to
lead a plays over yeah oh yeah because
he didn't have the key yeah so I woke up
I'm like man what the [ __ ] happened what
does cash come from because you know
ATMs is bogus over there's like it was
ATMs was not working it was hard to kid
I wake up it's his cash all on the bed
but you can't even spend cuz you're
locked inside in there it's not there's
mine I go downstairs it's like I'll type
of snacks on the table like what for
this just [ __ ] from right
this dude's gone you come to ten minutes
later like what would you go Manny to
Africa spend class they have in Africa
African spring classes like everything
so cut off yet it's just mean is one
lady in there okay yeah we're the
cycling class it hasn't caught up it
hasn't caught on over you at least tell
everybody it was the 5:45 5:45 classes
some people go to 5:45 yeah but I want
to get it in before work that's crazy
yeah 45 easily turns to 6:30 my body of
this seven yeah and it's the morning
time right rain like can't even process
[ __ ] once you start I don't hit up the
5:30 classes that often but when I do I
have a great day because you just get it
going you get the brain going energy gel
you feel accomplished cuz you're done
with your workout by 6:30 your heart
pound is it in a perfect world I wish
that worked for me but I'm such a such
not a morning person that when I hear
about people just waking up and [ __ ]
doing burpees and getting crazy alright
what the [ __ ] how does that like my yeah
I don't know guess what
abrupt ending to the podcast his solos
is all
[Music]
[Music]